Bubble sort, or sinking sort, is a naive
approach, like I described before.
You will go through your array
comparing elements side by side and
switching them whenever necessary.
Let me illustrate with a quick example.
We'll start at the beginning and
we'll compare the first two elements.
If the first element is bigger than
the second one, we'll switch them.
Great, we've made one switch, so
now we can move on over
to the next two elements.
Looks like we need to
switch here as well.
All right, now we can move
along to the next two elements.
And again, looks like our first element
is bigger than our second one, so
we'll need to switch.
Okay, now we can compare the last
two elements in the array.
And once again, the first element
is bigger than the second one, so
we'll need to switch.
All right,
now we're done with this round.
Okay, now that we've passed
through the array one time,
we should count up the number
of comparisons we needed.
It took us four comparisons
to get through five elements.
I think it's safe to say
that our runtime for
this step was n-1 since
the array size was five.
So with our n-1 comparisons,
what actually changed?
The array is still not actually sorted,
but it looks a little bit better now.
The largest element, 8, moved up to
the end of the array where it belongs.
This is actually why this
method is called bubble sort.
In each iteration the largest element in
the array will bubble on up to the top.
So by that logic,
in the next iteration the number 7
should bubble up to right below 8.
Let's repeat the process.
Again, we're going to start at the
bottom and work our way up to the top.
Looks like we need to
switch on our first step.
Let's move to step two now.
It looks like we actually don't need
to flip these two for the first time.
This first element is actually
less than that second element, so
we have nothing to do, awesome.
We do need to flip 7 and 0 though.
And the last two elements are in order,
so no work here.
Again, we had to do four steps,
which is still n-1.
Okay, now we're going to have to
do two more rounds of this, but
I don't want to bore
you with the details.
Let me show you what the next
iteration of comparisons looks like.
I did another iteration,
but not much has changed.
I just had to flip the 3 and
the 0 to look like this.
Again, the biggest element left, 3,
bubbled up to the place it belongs, but
we still have work to do.
And again, note that this took
four steps, so n-1 steps.
We only have one iteration left.
Let me show you what that looks like.
This time we only had to flip the 0 and
the 1, and we're done.